[Music]
so in all the studies that have been
done on the pay gap it's overwhelmingly
a pregnancy gap yes we should know but
hold on in which case why should women
be penalized for getting pregnant
exactly and that's because the feminism
that we've had has been patriarchal
because the type of feminism liberal
feminism that we've advanced was the
feminism autonomy that didn't recognize
that women have children and also the
overwhelming majority want to care for
those children and the pay gap is up to
the age of 30 women with degrees have
higher wages than men with degrees women
women women out-compete men in all forms
of education up to and including
university level now in and the
pregnancy pay gap is essentially the pay
gap is essential because we haven't
provided for women who have children at
the scale needed and when women have
children they come they move out of the
workforce when they come back they're on
a non career pathway there are lower
rates and they part time so in society
which is made for men as hasn't adjusted
to the reality of know what actually
happened is the type of feminism that
took legislative form was a patriarchal
type that didn't account for for
feminists for the difference of women
and the difference of women bearing and
having children I am more feminist I
would argue precise because I want that
to be catered for so you're
contradicting yourself
I thought your saying is I'm not a
patriarchy because I want to alter what
is a still a patriarchal system so
you've just acknowledged in advance of
your own case that the system is still
based on kids often I have said I have
said that the patriarchy that has
emerged is that is stale dominant is
primarily a possession of liberal
feminism because liberal feminism listen
to this liberal feminism advances
autonomy then the nature where women are
blocked is when they are non autonomous
and the prime point when they're non
autonomous is when they have children
and that was advanced by the liberal
feminism this
in the 1960s what I'm saying is as a
more radical feminist than that type of
offer the great danger is liberal
feminism if we really want to be radical
feminists we have to cater for the
difference that women have and when in
possess and the trouble is is most
liberal feminism doesn't do this at a
point to point to hold on I was told you
on this point because there are too many
points below forgive me what you've seem
to be advocating as far as I understand
it is one a patriarchy did exist to in
our society the results of that are
still evident three your solution is a
different form of feminism but it
doesn't deny the fact that the vestiges
if you like of that patriarchy are still
existing and are still pertinent and
affecting people so for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you